so how do you go full time with a small
channel and do you actually need tons of
views and subscribers or your channel
even to be monetized in order to make a
significant living on youtube the answer
is you don't in fact in this video i'm
going to be breaking down how currently
i'm earning
970 dollars per day without youtube
monetization now full disclose
disclosure
disclaimer i am monetized and this is
just one of my income streams but i'm
going to be revealing the results of how
i do this in this video i'm also going
to be
sharing an unlikely story of a creator
named mary and how she used this
strategy to create extra revenue pay her
bills i'm going to be sharing the really
bizarre story of how i talked about
coffee pods in my apartment in irvine
california a few years a few years ago
ago and ended up earning money every day
from selling verismo coffee pods it's
super strange i know and i'm gonna be
breaking down a few tips about how you
can do this even if you're just starting
out on youtube or if you want to earn
more money on youtube so definitely
stick around until the end because we
have a lot of juicy content to get into
today but if we're just meeting my name
is sean cannell and this is the coffee
with kennel show let's get into it
[Music]
yeah yeah oh all right welcome back to
the coffee with kennel show my name is
sean cannell um so i pulled a screenshot
up here
of my
amazon affiliate account and in the last
30 days specifically june 2019
29 june 29 2022 through july 28 2022
i earned 29 310.70
now obviously results are not typical
that's a pretty significant amount of
money to earn on amazon associates
but if you do the math and you divide
this number by 30 that ends up being 970
dollars a day now this is not youtube ad
revenue this is not youtube paying me
adsense to earn that money that is
directly from amazon paying me and you
don't even have to be monetized in order
to
do that and so i want to talk about the
strategy
um for
how to do this in just a second but the
first thing i actually do want to touch
on that i do believe will be worth your
time is kind of just this question of is
it too late to start youtube um and is
there too much competition right now
like why youtube like why is youtube
also specifically purposeful for this
strategy well you know forbes said that
video is where we need to be in 2022 but
i just saw this
the
brand new numbers came out that youtube
officially has 2.6 billion users
worldwide 2.6 billion now the last time
i looked at this it was 2.3 that means
300 million new users have joined the
youtube platform to watch content that
have a gmail account and are logged in
that's what this math tells us
now there's more than that that actually
watch youtube without being logged in
but that's a massive number so you may
feel like competition is going up and
it's hard to stand out how do i make it
as a small channel as a brand new
channel but the truth is yes competition
is rising but so is consumption there's
never been a bigger demand for high
quality content and so when you use what
we're going to be talking about in this
video it could be very powerful for
helping you make an impact and earning
good money
also youtube is in over a hundred
countries and is available in 80
languages so you can use this strategy
anywhere in the world and if you haven't
heard being a content creator is now the
fastest growing type of small business
from a report done in signalfire they
discovered this but i just wanted you to
see that influencer marketing hub
revealed that two million global content
creators are now making six figures so
while you may feel like you're in the
frustrating beginning you may feel like
you see other people making it other
people posting videos and crushing you
may feel like there's a lot of people
even like me that seem to be spewing
hype i'm not trying to over hype
anything i'm really just trying to share
the real data because when i share 970 a
day which is outrageous but it's a real
thing like where is all this money
coming from like this like two million
content creators making six figures it's
because this is how you do it like this
is what we're talking about in this
video like real money is being
transferred to real people working from
home
and so how are they doing it well my
favorite strategy is what i want to talk
about but the last thing is that the
creator economy is currently valued at
20 billion dollars with estimations that
it could grow to 104.2 billion
this year in 2022 that's 5x growth so i
know that we've had two quarters of
negative gdp here in the u.s and i know
that the white house doesn't think that
we're in a recession um and who knows
and who cares i mean i know it's a big
deal and it affects people but like
regardless if the stock market's going
down and tech stocks are going down
which they are the creator economy is
going up like this is a real thing that
is growing and that's what the data is
ultimately telling us so you want to get
in front of this 5x growth opportunity
and i've discovered that youtube is
healthy growing and the most profitable
platform to ultimately establish your
brand so let's talk about it i want to
talk about this strategy and this is the
one strategy that i use to generate 970
per day that's from amazon associates
it's actually kind of the tip of the
iceberg because there's a lot of other
programs we're a part of but that is the
most lucrative one and so let's look at
this um here's the strategy and you can
write this down take notes maybe hit the
like button if you're getting value and
maybe share this with somebody like is
do you find the stuff valuable on this
channel
sean i've never seen this channel before
okay well then don't share it um but if
you're getting value hit the like button
here's the strategy review specific
products
um on youtube this is the youtube
strategy review specific products now
wait you might say sean listen i'm not a
product review channel
i don't review products
i don't want to talk about products i
don't want listen you don't have to only
be a product review channel what we're
actually going to discover is that doing
this strategy you can actually generate
massive revenue
and subscriber growth
while building super fans
and creating a
win-win-win-win-win scenario where
people are pumped that they're learning
something they discover you if you're
unknown
and you can make money without being
monetized so this is just one strategy
in your tool belt in fact at think media
there's 16 core strategies we teach like
in our main program called video ranking
academy this is one of the 16. you could
do all 16 of them you in fact you
probably should use 80 of them this is
one of them okay so here's what it is
here's what i discovered
have you ever seen these before this is
like a massage gun you know
use this on your calves your uh your
shoulder blades you've been working on a
computer
if you're a runner if you've been
working out you see something like these
massage guns now i just want you to
imagine for a second that you have a
fitness channel let me know what your
niche is in the comments
let's say you have a fitness channel so
this this channel up here
life beckons tv does a video called
theragun vs hypervolt massage gun
all right
look at the amount of views this video
got
166 000 views
wow
just talking about two different massage
guns now look this video 266 000 views
p uh rehab talking about a couple
different massage guns
so what's interesting when you use this
strategy rsp review specific products
you don't actually just you're going to
make money we'll talk about that in a
second
but you can get a lot of views using
this strategy
watch you can also attract your ideal
audience because if you're talking about
the right products
then whatever your whoever your target
audience is the type of subscriber you
want to gain
by talking about certain products or
comparing two different products when
people are searching or browsing youtube
and youtube is suggesting them videos
boom your video gets recommended and
whether you earn money at all you can
also get discovered so stu a lot of
people have kind of a myopic criticism
of this strategy because they're like
you know
now i'm not a product review champ you
don't have to be a product review
channel you could just be a fitness
channel
but every once in so often it would be
relevant to talk about specific
products so if you've known me for any
length of time you know that on think
media
i've kind of become known as one of the
camera guys right the youtube camera guy
best camera for youtube i've been making
the best camera for youtube video
probably since 2015. and it's always
changing too by the way because there's
always new cameras but all that to say
is uh
i made a video called best camera for
youtube and m50 versus the sony a6400 it
got a million views right
and so
this is where things get interesting
from using the strategy rsp review
specific products there is a month in
april of 2020 where i earn nearly forty
thousand dollars
in fact it's kind of weird because cnbc
did a mini documentary about it you can
look it up it's like a 10 minute video
kind of shares my story i'm a small town
kid college dropout
started to shoot making videos in my
bedroom and that's not 40 000 in gross
revenue that's 40 dollars in profit now
explain how that explains the story
there you can look it up sean cannell
cnbc you can search it on google if you
care but all that to say
was you can make real money reviewing
specific products so here's jennifer
doing the sewing report and she does
like a diy channel
you know easy sewing techniques easy
baby gifts embroidery machines you know
different kind of things she uh
she here's a couple videos she did
notice this the videos are also a couple
years old so going deeper on the
strategy
one of the powerful things about doing
this is it's not just
the views you get today but when you put
out an rsp video and you review a
specific product or you do a product
comparison
the video can keep getting washed
whenever someone's at that minute before
a buying decision they might go look for
the video and search
like do i want to get the uh brother pe
800 embroidery machine let me go check
it out have you ever done that before by
the way have you ever searched
online for information about a product
or a product comparison you probably
have and if you haven't you probably
will someday
and so
these videos get views 24 7 365 for
years on end
so now think about it this is not the
only kind of video jennifer makes
diy crafting sewing pillows quilts
but when she does
not only does the video two years old
and has gotten hundreds of thousands of
views
not only has it led to her growing
subscriber she's almost 100 000
subscribers now
but also she's able to earn money
because she's also talking about these
products she sent me a dm and i think
one of these brother machines cost her
around 750 and this is her passion and
hobby anyways
but she earned four thousand dollars
through affiliate marketing talking
about the product and unless you think
because sometimes people go this
kind of sounds scammy what's affiliate
marketing it's kind of a horrible
horrible term right
like
this is not scammy there are scammy
people who do it
who
if you're a scammy person
then it becomes scammy but ultimately
what affiliate marketing is is it's just
a cool way to make money
sharing about products you personally
love and use that you would recommend to
friends and family anyways you're just
able to make money in the process
and i'll explain a little bit more about
that in a second but like it becomes
ultimately a win-win-win-win as a
creator you can earn money talking about
stuff you love and use
products
like companies that need to sell things
can get in front of their potential
audience you also watch you can help
people avoid products they should not
purchase and save money don't you wish
there was somebody a friend on the
internet who could actually be like oh
don't buy that one get this one instead
well i tried that but it broke after six
months so you're you're there to help
you're there to serve it's a cool way to
earn money sharing products you love and
use and uh it's called affiliate
marketing you also this is an example of
doing it in network marketing so tlc is
called total life changes they sell like
skin care and stuff and you could do
something like a one month review like
look one month update
of of talking about
skin uh drops review for like skin care
what's the point the point is like
it's not even just
review a product you could say unboxing
is one way to do it
uh
impressions after one month
one year later how's it still holding up
this versus that i want to compare this
product to that product
subscription box or something like that
you just open it up you talk about
what's in there like the rsp strategy
goes really deep like the review
specific products and it doesn't
actually have to be a review it could be
a first impressions you might not be
ready to review it you haven't verified
and tested it and clocked enough hours
on it yet you maybe don't understand it
yet you don't know
if it's cleared your skin up the moment
you open it in the box that's okay you
go hey
i'm here's here's the results today come
back one month later and
in a way network marketing is similar to
affiliate marketing they're different
uh but again you could have a link in
the description and say hey the
product's great it's helping my skin
whatever and you can earn money in the
process
um
this is uh heather
taurus and you probably know her from
the thick media podcast she's our host
she also has a channel called the
homeschool house uh her heather taurus
channel she's really passionate about
homeschool her husband isaiah have three
kids they love homeschool they actually
um
talk they reviewed their homeschool
curriculum
and every year her and her husband
isaiah have
they purchased homeschool curriculum at
sixteen hundred dollars
and what she thought after she built her
channel up she only had like 2 000
subscribers so not 100 million like mr
beast just hit but just a few
subscribers she reached out to the
company that makes the curriculum and
said hey would you consider if i made
like a video for you guys talking about
your product would you consider sending
us the product for free or doing some
kind of a brand partnership or affiliate
partnership and they replied
and they said like
what the heck are you even talking about
like what is a brand partnership
affiliate activation influencer deal you
know what i mean like they don't even
know but she then explained it like they
didn't even know they had no way to do
it but she actually got in touch with
them and they go sounds interesting
let's talk and they gave her a promo
code
so if anyone purchased
their uh the homeschool curriculum
through her link and used her code she
got 10 10 commission which
on a 1600 homeschool curriculum that's
160 dollars so you do the math but she
also got the curriculum for free
and so she's biz deving business
development
as a youtube creator around review
specific products you know i just showed
you earlier how we do 970
a day
view via amazon affiliates but again on
think media talking about tech best
camera under fifteen hundred dollars is
the canon m50 still the best camera um
earlier this year is about thirty two
thousand 000 in a month so it fluctuates
but it maps to around you know a
thousand dollars a day now which is
pretty crazy and i mean here's another
one i did review specific products uh
best greens powder organifi green juice
review and this was it doesn't have to
be tech you know it could be home school
it could be health related there's a lot
of different things and again you don't
have to make this every single video on
your channel you can do this um
as just one video that is
a way to earn money and still grow your
channel and serve your audience at the
same time but the reason i am so
passionate about this strategy is
because you can start earning money
quickly
you don't have to be monetized and
that's a big deal because you need money
for the mission
like maybe you need money to be able to
go part-time at work or you need money
to quit your job fully or you want money
to hire an editor
and again
under the idea of like how do you go
full time on youtube it's one of my
favorite ways you start making content
you start leveraging affiliate marketing
and you tap into the power of reviewing
specific products now what can happen is
you can look for affiliate programs that
are better than amazon and one example
would be what i did here was because you
know i found i'm a health kind of nut i
like to
bio hack and i buy all these vitamins
and all this green juice stuff and this
is actually powdered green juice for
when you travel i learned about it from
my friend louis and so after i purchased
the product tried it out myself loved it
i made a video about it
now i just sat in front of my window and
just shot you know
just set the camera up talked about the
product the video was very simple it's
very basic
but i had
tested the product i had done my
research on it i had used it myself and
i just shared what i knew you could see
the video is eight minutes long well
here's what's interesting a lot of times
on amazon when i talk about a camera i
earn four percent if someone clicks my
link and buys something or if they buy a
camera you get four percent for tech
for conversation sake if the camera is a
thousand dollars i would earn forty
dollars unless i'm wrong i'm not good at
math and so
in this case though you can find
affiliate programs that pay you more
than four percent so for this green
juice i earn
uh 30
and watch if they subscribe
to get a bottle of organifi monthly
i actually
get paid on what's called continuity and
i get 30
every single month so if somebody
subscribes to that product
and they stick with their subscription
for a year then every single month the
money's coming in even though i only
made a youtube video one time somebody
watched the video somebody clicked the
link somebody purchased the product and
subscribed and now every time their
credit card gets billed i'm getting a
piece of that transaction transaction 30
percent can you say wow and uh
can you say wow backwards in the
comments maybe flip it upside down
mom
so stupid
listen hey i almost have a two-year-old
and have another baby on the way i'm
gonna bring the dad jokes okay that's
what you get here on uh on the think
media podcast channel and uh that's all
that's all i can really deliver for you
but anyways um it's it's a big wow it's
it's pretty it's pretty amazing and so
here's the sales page like you know they
click the link they go to this page and
i'm able to sign up as an affiliate and
so um i want to introduce you to joseph
and mary in just a second tell you a
little bit more about how to do this but
specifically um i actually am about to
go hang with the fam i just wanted to
get this in front of you today this
coffee with kennel is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
um if you're interested in a whole deep
dive class about this
i just finished it up the replay is
available for a limited time on demand
thinkmasterclass.com
here's the full thing friend
we're hanging out here on youtube you're
watching this video i appreciate you
being here i've also put a class that is
exclusive premium content for free at
thinkmasterclass.com all you do is you
enter your name and email so i can email
you the class
and a private viewing link because again
it's content that we normally just have
reserved inside of our course called
video ranking academy there's 60 minutes
of value on that class at the end of it
i'll tell you more about our online
course what's his is he trying to trick
is he trying to trick us
into going to watch the i'm not trying
to trick you into doing anything i'm
telling you exactly everything that is
happening
and just trying to add as much value as
possible
and if you want to do like more business
with us or like learn about our
community where we have really
passionate purpose-driven entrepreneurs
that are just really going deep in all
this kind of stuff as well as obviously
getting into the
the step by step by step-by-step
everything that's just what's waiting
for you at the end of the rabbit
hole right
thickmasterclass.com so um that's it and
it's a really high value class it's at
thinkmasterclass.com
um i got a really cool case study from
joseph mary and i want to answer some of
your questions about this but check this
out and i'm going to take a sip coffee
with candle today is brought to you by
sparkling hop tea because i'm not
drinking coffee but i'll be right back
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
yeah
okay listen we're talking about review
specific products the best strategy i
believe for going full-time on youtube
it's exactly how i was able to quit my
job go all in eventually build a
six-figure income
um
and then scale from there was
making youtube videos
not just reviewing products but
ultimately tapping into affiliate
marketing and this kind of an example so
meet joseph right
so he makes a channel called grow with
guitar
now when you do a guitar channel think
about all the videos you could do and
here's some recommendations if you had a
guitar channel how to play a particular
song
easy chords for a new trending song
because people are looking for it
you're teaching people how to play the
chords that's are you going to make
money with like affiliate marketing to
that probably not
but should you do that video absolutely
you might make a video that's more
evergreen
like
scales how to do a basic scale and
people can watch that anytime it's not
based on trends it's just evergreen how
to do a scale okay you might make a
video that is about
practicing and finger dexterity you
might make you know things every
beginner guitar player should know okay
so there's all kinds of videos you
should make
and you can also do
review specific products like so it's
all it could be on brand on trend
i'm not like a guitar tech review
channel i don't want to do well then
don't you don't have to do this too by
the way like why are you still here i'm
just kidding like but i mean you know
like ultimately
sometimes
i feel the energy it's like i don't want
to be listen this is all i'm trying to
do is help you make money okay and help
you serve people
and have it be a win-win in the process
so notice what growth guitar did here so
joseph
finds kind of a niche he starts talking
about headphone
amplifiers okay
and
look at this eighteen thousand views
forty two thousand views
and
he's talking about vox amp and plug two
headphone amp shout out all the
different models
and then he has amazon affiliate links
to these
headphone amplifiers i believe musical
instruments yeah i think you get five
percent four percent i mean and so let's
look it up let's check out these uh
vox headphone amplifiers
and so someone's looking for a review of
this stuff they go over to amazon
right they find these different
headphone amps
79
someone checks out his video they click
his link they come over here they make a
purchase
he gets four percent of that he's making
hundreds of dollars i forget when he
started his channel but i want to say
he's like 17.
and i'll i wasn't
making hundreds of dollars at 17. i
don't know why my video is tripping out
i hope it looks good for you
um and so
that's it right super cool and he's
reviewing specific product it's not the
only kind of video you have to make
it's the only kind uh it's just one that
is a great way to earn money now once
you're signed up for the amazon
affiliate program let me also show you
you obviously have to qualify and we're
not going to go into all that here but
look up here see this little link here
this is how i get my custom link
quickly it says at the top of the screen
amazon associates and i can just copy
paste that link and that is how i put
that in my youtube description
that is how
amazon tracks everybody tracks and
ultimately
uh you know then if someone clicks on it
makes a purchase then i end up making
money so uh it's just once you're signed
up and approved
it's really easy to just go to these
different pages of amazon or whatever it
is find things that are relevant or find
the things that you already use sean are
you saying i should like go buy stuff i
don't have any money to buy stuff you
probably already have stuff
like because you should make a youtube
channel about what you're already
passionate about what you're already
investing in what you already spend
money on which you already research
which you're already geeking out on
which you are already into
like that's
that's the model like i was
started shooting video from my local
church in 2003
i started a business for doing wedding
videography and music videos for like
local seattle hip-hop rap artists and
stuff in 2009 so i had cameras that i
purchased anyways i actually took a loan
out to get the cameras
and i'm hustling to start my small
business
but then i'm like wait a minute i bought
this cameras and these lenses anyways
and these things were expensive wait i
could go monetize from what i already
have
i could go answer questions and do
tutorials about these
and also create extra streams of income
well this is cool
and so that's the dream the strategy is
rsp review specific products so what
products could you review or compare do
they and then ask yourself do they have
an affiliate program
do they have an affiliate program drop
some in the chat what is a product you
could review uh that
or compare and does it have an affiliate
program
and and there's a way to look and
research to see
if uh if they have an affiliate program
i'll show you how um but what
what you want to do is we always teach
reverse engineer so you could sit down
and say okay
what kind of product would attract my
ideal audience
what is maybe something i already have
what is something people be interested
in
can i go see if it has an affiliate
program it does you could sign up then
you get all your ducks in a row and then
you can make your youtube video
and start putting that out there so
cooking with hilda says cooking tools of
course you could go to you know amazon
and there's like endless uh cooking
tools but this these could be all types
of things you you make about wooden
kitchen spoons best wooden kitchen
spoons
uh best knives you could also do you
know silicone versus wooden spatulas
so you could you could compare two
different types of videos i swear my
computer's about to melt um maybe not
but i
things are not looking good over here
the millennium falcon is losing power
chewy i need help uh
okay so
uh what else do you got out there though
gaming accessories gaming accessories so
that's a good it's a great one because
sometimes people think well how does
this work for gaming playthroughs it
doesn't you wouldn't do this for a
gaming play through but you would do it
for maybe your gaming setup uh you would
do it for hey let me show you my desk
setup i want to show you
i want to show you the led lights i used
for my gaming setup i want to show you
my mechanical keyboard i want to show
you how i set up my ghetto seat uh deck
i want to show you my ergonomics that i
use for gaming
so that i stay healthy and keep my feet
comfortable
and my posture right i want to talk
about my chair i want to talk about see
there's all kind of products in
different niches
right that you can ultimately
ultimately do and uh
oh i gotta block the spam person i put
them in timeout oh i can block them here
awesome
solo round on coffee with kennel we're
out here smash the like button writers i
see uh i see you leia um you could do
apps as well apps are great you could do
different apps different software um
that's a really good one uh
hair products for natural hair carry
that's a really good one
that uh you could do and so um again
you might go well i don't know if
there's enough ideas for this to be the
only type of video that i do
no big deal
it's like one of the videos you upload a
year
one of the videos you upload a month
however what's cool is it's one of the
best ways for you to start generating
money
and so uh
definitely something to
to check out i'm getting calls i'm
getting spam comments i'm getting hit up
from everywhere my computer's melting
our pet's heads are falling off
anybody
is anybody
that's a niche reference that wouldn't
have made sense otherwise okay let's
land the plane today listen uh i want to
tell you about mary too this is a pretty
crazy story so so we're talking about
review specific uh products uh let me
know what product could be relevant for
your target audience your channel niche
uh what category of products it could be
software it could be physical it could
be ecom it could be events it could be
tickets
it could be coaching it could be online
courses it could be members there's a
lot of different things uh but i want
you to meet mary so you know some of
these people these are our video ranking
academy students like people that have
been a part of our program mary actually
had never uploaded a video before
and uh she now says one of the favorite
phrases in our community she says just
put the apron on and i don't feel like
filming just put the apron on because
she films in her kitchen and uh she
lives in texas
and in a small rural texas community at
our local church actually kids come up
to her and they're like you're famous
she's like what she has 500 000
subscribers on youtube now it's crazy
and so anyway she makes videos like this
like how to make homemade apple cider
vinegar with the mother anybody who
drinks apple cider vinegar nose you want
that mother in there and so that's like
a piece of a mushroom right it's like a
fermented
slimy mushroom that you drink
does that sound good okay so 546
thousand views pretty crazy right
and so she'll do videos too like how to
make simple roast chicken before your
next video just if you're feeling
nervous to get on camera just put the
apron on you know
just punch fear in the face put the
apron on and so she has figured out and
really through our program too she ranks
a lot of videos her videos are found in
search uh and suggested and um through
kind of going through some of the stuff
we teach but here's one of the things
she does
is she has not only set up a website but
for certain videos she does she has set
up a shopping guide so here's mary's
nest shop on amazon
so over time eventually too you don't
have to be a quote unquote amazon
influencer but there's a program called
amazon influencers where you get your
own page you apply
and so here's her page she's got
emergency preparedness gardening
supplies
she's got her food preservation
equipment her cookbook library
her favorite canning equipment
her favorite board games so over time
she's
won
generally
as she builds up her community people
can go to this page and just discover
this stuff
two she can make specific videos that
even lead to specific lists or
categories or groups of
products
and so do you see how powerful this is
now imagine having a video like mary
that has
546 000 views you know
and then how much awareness that could
bring
into
your affiliate marketing but it doesn't
stop there um she also it's not just
amazon she's also signed up for things
like mock milk and you can use her link
which is how it tracks
for affiliate marketing
to get a milk alternative product
right which is now another income stream
u.s wellness meets
bread smart and so you can go to her u.s
wellness meets link
right you get a discount it's affiliate
marketing order some 100 grass-fed beef
that they'll ship over to you
um
and
ultimately is my computer working is my
internet broken we'll see if that loads
and so um
here we go
and
grass fed pasture raised meats
um and use this is her tracking leak
link you can actually see it up here at
the top of the screen very small but it
says cj so it's probably commission
junction or or whatever event and
there's her tracking like it's just the
point that doesn't matter the technical
side of course does matter but like um
you could see so many different niches
and ways you could do this and there's
affiliate programs for like
nordstrom and target and dick's sporting
goods and bass pro shop
and our style and ulta
and
sephora i mean anything you could pretty
much think of
j crew
anthropology i mean i don't know like
what do we
what are you looking for um because more
and more the world's also moving towards
e-commerce
especially with not only pandemics or
lockdowns we've been through but
potentially future lockdowns so there's
really never been a better time to
position yourself
in front of this 5x growth the crater
economy's been experiencing using this
strategy
of rsp review specific
products um and so
if you want to learn
again more about this i wanted to get
you the big idea in front of you of
course
make sure you're subscribed here on
think media podcast
also check out our audio podcast which
is on spotify and apple because we
continue to teach and do more stuff
about this but if you also really want
to learn more about this specific thing
how to set this up and really the
there's there's it's not i never want to
claim anything's easy
and i suggest avoiding following people
who you know say oh it's just super easy
and all of a sudden you know i posted
one video and a million dollars was
transferred to my bank account overnight
like this stuff takes hard work hustle
and it really takes obviously nuances of
making the right videos in the right way
structuring the details and all that and
that's that's where we can help you if
you're interested in going deeper with
all that kind of information and so i've
been doing this now for over a decade i
made a lot of mistakes i started to kind
of understand this a little bit and i
remember my first commission from amazon
was only two dollars and 12 cents but
now it's up to 970 a day so i've
definitely made a ton of mistakes i've
done the things wrong and i've really
figured out how to do this sustained
sustainably and also scale up that
revenue so i did teach that in a class
recently if you want to check it out
thinkmasterclass.com if you have a
question put four question marks before
and after the question i'll get to just
a couple here today before i go to lunch
with my son uh and uh check this out
i'll be right back are you ready to
start or grow your youtube channel do
you feel stuck and need help connecting
the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
welcome back
to coffee with kennel my name is sean
cannell what are you drinking today i'm
drinking some hop lark hop tea the citra
bomb one
30 milligrams of caffeine
cheers
if you know somebody who should uh
uh see this would you mind sharing this
out
um that would mean the world to me hit
the like button if you're getting value
and uh if you got a question go ahead
and drop some question marks before and
after
um let me answer just a couple of your
questions today on the show
and let me know your biggest aha moment
and what you're thinking about
oh i didn't share the coffee story
because i'm inspired now because daily
mom living is drinking coffee
gaming mom is drinking coffee
and i should be drinking coffee because
it's the coffee with kennel
show
but this is an example of how to do this
so um once i figured out
the fact that youtube is a search engine
the fact that people are looking to
answer specific questions they want to
learn about certain things
back in um
around 2015 i was in irvine california
this was our part apartment i was
actually a campus pastor at the time
working at a church
and i had i was gifted this starbucks
verismo machine but i quickly learned
that the pods for the verismo machine
were outrageously expensive they were
like just as much as going to starbucks
um so i was like okay
what good is this machine on a pastor's
salary trying to do my side hustle and
this is part of the reasons why i was
doing a side hustle uh cost of living
here was expensive trying to support my
family um and so i was over at a
friend's house and they had the same
machine but they were using these
different pods these cbtl pods
now i was like well this is crazy these
fit they work and they're like yeah they
do like we tried them they fit in this
verismo machine i was like okay
so i went home and my mine was already
turning because i was already making
youtube videos and whatnot and i went
home and i
researched to see okay i said where do
you get the pods and they bought them
from the the website like cbl cbtl's
exact website
but i love amazon the most because
amazon most people already have account
most people have amazon prime and a lot
of times it's even discounted more and
one of the big unlocks is you want to
remove friction meaning
if you i don't know about you if you go
to a website you've never been on and
you're like i literally have to make an
account and like enter my credit card
information it's too hard
suit that's too difficult so what i did
right is i always like amazon's my
favorite because it's the lowest amount
of friction so sure enough i found cbtl
pods on amazon
and uh ordered some verified it for
myself that they actually worked and
before i did any of that i actually went
home and did some topic research and
discovered that sure enough
there was
a lot of people that were curious
do
cbtl pods work in starbucks for esmo
like that was actually a search phrase
people were looking for turns out 160
200 views later and then notice in the
description see it says check out cbtl
pods for starbucks for smoke here
you can click this link
takes you over to the pods
i sell coffee every day
like you didn't know i was coffee with
cannel
it should be the name of the show that's
right the coffee with kennel show
um
and so anyways um ultimately
i literally hope my cpu is not about to
to to melt maybe because it's 80 degrees
outside
i
is it glitching on your end let me know
if you see little glitches in the video
or if that's just my monitors
because
i am worried that's okay
um
the computer would probably warn me
wouldn't it
who cares let's keep going so ultimately
uh
i'm selling coffee every day
because a video continues to be found
it's got a link in the the description
and um it's pretty cool all right well
let me try to not share my screen as
much and maybe that's
why but uh we'll
we'll shut it down here
so much for this nzxt
gaming pc that i don't even use for
gaming that i'm trying to live stream
with
and i can't even share my screen on
stream yard
but i digress so let me hit a couple
questions um and here we go if i provide
a link to a product page would amazon
pay me for any of the products on from
that company's page yeah the cool thing
is
um it actually doesn't even mean just
that company's page
if someone clicks your link
for 24 hours
anything they buy on amazon
you'll get credit for
so if you're the last link they clicked
and they go over to amazon and and so
imagine someone's like do cbtl pods work
in starbucks for respond they find my
video they click my link but then they
don't buy this the coffee pods they go
oh cool that's good to know and i'll
save that for later oh but you know what
i do need toilet paper oh that's right
my son's birthday is coming up and i did
he's been good i'm buying him a ps5 i'd
get credit for all that stuff
that's one of the big reasons also why
amazon can be so powerful is
um you you are going to get paid for
anything within 24 hours if you were the
last click
how easy is it to set up the affiliate
partnership
you could just google amazon associates
and start going through the steps it's
pretty easy
you got to do your due diligence
and but that's what i would do how many
videos should you make that's a really
good question i i wouldn't think about
it as in like a minimum amount of videos
to make
and then like
now you're set and you can go to the
cayman islands and you've got passive
income coming in like crazy
i would actually think of it more as
like a lifestyle
um i think you really start to see
momentum on youtube on the other side of
30 to 50 smart videos
you should post 30 to 50 videos just to
kind of start like stretching out your
content creation chops like just getting
used to making content getting
comfortable on camera testing you need a
good sample size 30 to 50 videos but
some people go i posted 50 videos and
that momentum as it started i go look
and i'm like yeah they suck though sorry
i mean i mean it i'm like you did the
titles don't make sense they're you're
barely titling them you're not even
uploading custom thumbnails
the videos don't even they're
you didn't put like thought into them
they're not like a substantive strategic
dialed in strategic
you know
solid effort
i'm not putting
them down or you down as the individual
like you're not able
to create a good video i mean you don't
have you have to to sit down and like
make a good thumbnail with canva like
actually write a good title and and more
than that
actually make a video people want to
watch a lot of times people do 50 videos
they didn't even review one specific
product they didn't answer any specific
questions it's just a bunch of random
nonsense and they're like it's just not
going viral i'm like well obviously so
all that to say
is i really think you could see some
momentum
after 10 20 30 40 50 videos
you'll get there faster if you follow
some of our formulas and youtube best
practices in general
but more than that
create a lifestyle of creating content
why
because
you'll make your first twenty dollars
through affiliate marketing as described
in this video
but then it'll turn into two hundred but
then it'll turn into 2000 and then that
might be
those might be around your ambitions or
what do you want to do i want to work
part-time on youtube have youtube pay my
bills
or you want to build a team and change
the world like my ambition at think
media so now we have 25 people on the
team so like i'm trying to the revenue
we're generating
is supporting families and helping us
scale and do bigger projects and be more
creative and create better content for
you so
how many videos should you make
a lot like it's a lifestyle like keep
making them like start making them
start small start at your own pace it's
your race your pace don't get anxious
about it
don't don't feel weird fear of missing
out or pressure from externals just head
down on your stuff one a week if you can
but kind of get into that content
lifestyle because content can become
something you make a living from
and then something that you create as a
habit as a routine and it can become
your main thing and ultimately your
full-time job as well
what would you recommend for reviewing a
children's author
audience
so if you're
this strategy
admittedly does not work if you can't
sell things
to kids is speci and you can't
so your amazon is against their terms of
service to market to children under 13.
um and so
uh in that particular case
conversely
you could go study ryan's toy reviews
and realize he's not really reviewing
toys but he really is he's unboxing he's
reviewing toys but it's not affiliate
marketing and ryan made 27 million
dollars last year so so you can actually
still do it i would just point you to
like
other kids channels to see
the clues you can learn they're doing
brand deals brand sponsorships brand
integrations and all kinds of things
like that listen um before my computer
melts i'm going to uh land the plane
here so and try to figure out um
why my processor or whatever is
overloaded but i want you to know i
appreciate you i'm grateful for you hit
like if you were getting value today if
you really want to learn more about this
um
i highly recommend checking out the
on-demand class we have the replay up
for a few days thinkmasterclass.com i
just recorded it two days ago super
excited about this information i
actually talk about how you can monetize
one youtube video in four different ways
i talk about how i invested
130 dollars and turned it into over 30
000 and i know these are big numbers but
i think what i hope to also be
encouraging you with in this is
that it is practical
to
start earning an extra 100 a week to
earn an extra thousand dollars a month
to scale that up to a 32 thousand dollar
a year creator business
to scale that up to a six figure like
there's a lot of sometimes sensational
numbers and that's not my goal
but i just want to be transparent and
honest with the numbers i am sharing and
so this is real and if you're interested
in some of the nuances and details and
lessons i've learned head over to think
master class right now to watch the
replay on demand class of that it's 60
minutes long it'll answer some i'm sure
a lot of other questions are coming in
here um it'll help you with those as
well man i appreciate you i'm uh
grateful for you and i want to thank you
for being a part of the think media
think media podcast community my name is
sean cannell um and
i will see you in the next episode of
coffee with kennel peace